well you know the pandemic has changed
how employers are looking for workers
and with more people needing jobs in the
valley right now
it's more important than ever to really
stand out so you can land
a new gig hector mejia live this morning
down in henderson with some details on a
boot camp underway on this hector good
morning to you
you are a thousand percent right on that
john good morning to you and you know a
lot of people forget that you have to be
strategic
when you send out those resumes and you
apply to for jobs
joining us live we have our live studio
audience and sonia pedowak here
to talk to us all right so what should
you wear if you're doing a zoom
interview
and also how can you stand out good
morning to you good morning to you too
i think it's important to you know wear
neutral colors and and wear something
that speaks to your personality do your
research be professional if it's a very
uh
conservative and professional
environment be more casual if it's a
more casual environment
as a recruiter what are the top
questions you're getting right now and
how
are people adjusting during the pandemic
well i think a lot of it has to do with
what you've been doing
during pandemic if you've been
unemployed what have you done to invest
in yourself
to make yourself a more viable candidate
so in the instance of it have you been
taking courses have you been getting
certifications how are you making
yourself
stay up to date on what's happening in
that industry
in order to be someone who can hit the
ground running when you get the job
so for example if arthur has a job
interview through zoom
should he be wearing this shirt with a
tie or should he be wearing a polo
i think it really depends on the job if
you're going for like a banking job
go with the shirt and tie but if you're
going for maybe a casino or just a
more casual corporate one i don't think
there's anything wrong with a polo these
days the days of like suit and tie
and jacket are kind of over and here's a
question so how can you be strategic
well i think that's a great thing i
think i was chatting with you earlier
about don't spray and pray with your
resume don't just send it out everywhere
look at each job description research
the company so when the client calls and
says hey we got your application
you're not just asking them who they are
and what you applied for oh i forgot i'm
just applying for every job be strategic
make a list you can go to our website
download a list to track your job search
which jobs are you applying for where
did you see them
and what is unique about that job so
when the client calls you can say oh
yeah
i saw your job i'm really interested in
working in a warehouse i'm really
interested in being in a corporate
environment you can sound like you're
really invested and authentic
for that job and also sonya you were
telling me when you're when it's time to
do the zoom interview
make sure you know where your pets are
yes like don't have a lot of
distractions i was joking about a call
that was on the other day where there
was a cat roaming around
or several cats yes and it's super
distracting it's hard i want to focus on
you i want to learn about you we have
limited time and a lot of candidates in
the market i want to get to know who you
are
and why you're a fit for my company and
my culture so try to make sure your
space is conducive to a very connected
authentic conversation
sonia thank you very much for the
insight hope that helps for anyone out
there who may be searching for a job
we'll be posting all the details on our
website and that is you know what that
website is eightnewsnow.com reporting
live in henderson hector mejia
and back to you guys all right hector
thank you very much did you say it's
it's arthur
arthur's looking for a job is that his
name arthur arthur arthur good luck to
arthur arthur
thanks